Traduttore: Maria Zatelli
Revisore: Claudia Ciniglio
Nel solo 2009 e soltanto negli Stati Uniti
140 istituti di credito hanno dichiarato
bancarotta.
Nello stesso anno, dopo aver studiato
economia, finanza e gestione,
dopo aver studiato
in italia, svizzera e stati uniti
mi sono laureato.
Ero il prodotto di quel sistema
ed ero stato formato
per pensare e agire come il sistema.
Visti i risultati, decisi di rinnegare
e di fare esattamente il contrario:
decisi di tornare in italia
e di aprire la mia di impresa.
Il giorno che decisi che tipo di struttura
dare alla mia impresa
eravamo in tre attorno al tavolo, oltre
a me c'erano i miei due attuali soci:
uno, un ingeniere con 15 anni
di conoscenza del settore del legno
e l’altro invece un manager con 20 anni
di conoscenza dei mercati esteri.
Avevamo background differenti
ma un piglio imprenditoriale
eccezionalmente simile.
Avevamo il desiderio di fare qualcosa
di radicalmente diverso e di così opposto
a quello che c'era sul mercato
da poter funzionare.
Più che innovare facendo
un balzo in avanti
volevamo innovare scartando di lato.
Prendemmo quindi un foglio bianco grande
e tracciamo una linea nel mezzo
Da una parte scrivevamo quello che c'era sul mercato,
quello che sta succedendo,
Dall'altra parte esattamente il contrario,
e noi avremmo fatto il contrario.
2009, quindi che tipo di nuove imprese c’erano,
che tipo di prodotti c'erano sul mercato?
Tendenzialmente app, social media,
facebook oppure consulenza: riga!
Allora noi avremmo fatto un prodotto,
avremmo fatto manifattura.
Bene, per fare manifattura serve una
visione di impresa, di prodotto.
Ed è curioso quando uno parla di visione
che strizza sempre un po' gli occhi.
Quindi noi, alla ricerca
di una visione chiara,
cercammo la cosa più
immediatamente pertinente a visione.
Visione, occhi, occhiali: faremo gli occhiali.
Sembrava una boutade, in realtà il mercato
dell'occhialeria è molto interessante:
si può sedurre il cliente finale parlando
di comfort, di design, di qualità.
Dal punto di vista di distribuzione
è abbastanza eterogeneo
quindi si può dialogare con ottici
indipendenti, con gruppi di acquisto.
Quindi sembrava un mercato
abbastanza poliedrico
da permettere di sedurre e attaccare
il cliente da diverse angolazioni.
Gli occhiali sono tendenzialmente
di acetato o metallo:
Riga! Noi faremo in legno.
Il legno è un materiale nobile,
caldo, elegante, molto contemporaneo
e soprattutto il mio socio
sapeva tutto del legno.
quindi occhiali di legno,
occhiali di legno sia.
E dove si fanno gli occhiali oggi?
Tendenzialmente dove costa di meno,
quindi in Cina o in Dongguan: riga!
Noi invece li faremo in Italia
con alta qualità.
Come in Italia? Tutti fanno outsourcing,
vanno a cercare fornitori specializzati.
Riga! noi invece non solo cercheremo
i fornitori specializzati altrove
ma faremo la nostra
manifattura di occhiali,
nella quale avremo la proprietà e il
controllo. Ma come la tua manifattura?
Tutti vanno alla ricerca di economie di
scala per mantenere il prezzo basso: riga!
Allora noi manterremo il prezzo alto
e i volumi solo attivati
dal venduto e dal pagato.
Ma come i volumi solo attivati
dal venduto e dal pagato?
Gli altri fanno il magazzino per essere
pronti a inondare il mercato
quando chiede qualcosa: Riga!
Noi daremo al mercato esattamente
quello che chiede, in poche settimane.
Ma come esattamente quello che chiede?
Gli occhiali sono tendenzialmente
l'80% neri o color tartaruga,
in realtà sono tutti uguali: riga!
Allora per la nostra manifattura di
occhiali in legno
le tre parole chiave saranno
design, colore e personalizzazione.
Ed ecco com'è nata la mia azienda.
Ad oggi la mia, la nostra azienda è la
ragione per la quale 20 dipendenti
della Val Brembana, una sessantina
di venditori in giro per il mondo
e qualche consulente
si alzano la mattina e vanno a lavorare.
è la ragione per la quale almeno
un migliaio dei migliori ottici del mondo
vanno al lavoro con un pizzico di orgoglio
in più per quello che fanno
Ed è la ragione per la quale un piccolo
grande esercito di consumatori ha deciso
di avere il proprio nome scritto
sull’occhiale,
non quello di qualchedun altro.
Nonostante partimmo da un approccio
provocatorio, da bastian contrario,
l’idea che che avevamo in testa
o meglio sul foglio sottendeva
un paradigma che era in grado di reggersi
se 5 condizioni cardine potevano rispettarsi.
E noi aderimmo e aderiamo
in modo tenace a quelle 5 condizioni.
La prima è che per fare manifattura in
Italia bisogna fare un prodotto
ad alto valore aggiunto, che quindi
può essere venduto ad un prezzo alto,
ma il prezzo deve essere giustificato
dalla qualità.
Nel nostro caso la qualità è giustificata
da 3 elementi:
la ricerca e sviluppo,
i macchinari e le persone.
La ricerca e sviluppo occupò 2 anni,
dal 2009 al 2011,
e fu interamente finanziata
da capitale privato.
I macchinari li sviluppammo ad hoc
qui sul territorio.
Per le persone, mettemmo facilmente
insieme un gruppo di persone
che erano state lasciate a casa
a causa della crisi.
Erano persone che lavoravano nel settore
del legno, quindi avevano lavorato
per molti anni magari prodotti poveri, una
gamba del tavolo, una testata del letto.
Dovete sapere che per fare un occhiale di
legno come il nostro è necessario avere
molta professionalità, molta manualità
e una cura del dettaglio maniacale.
Fu una vera epifania scoprire che
quando andavamo a fare formazione
ai nostri ragazzi, loro non solo avevano
l'innata capacità di fare quel prodotto,
ma guardandomi negli occhi sembravano
voler dire: ne abbiamo la capacità, anzi,
perchè mai nessuno ci ha chiesto di fare
un prodotto a così alto valore aggiunto?
La seconda condizione
del nostro paradigma, dopo qualità,
è la velocità di esecuzione.
Fare un prodotto, portarlo sul mercato,
venderlo, raccogliere i feedback
e ripetere.
La velocità di esecuzione è l'unica arma che
una piccola media impresa o startup app ha
per tutelarsi quando i competitor copiano.
Soprattutto in Italia, dove tutelarsi
dal punto di vista del know how
costa molti soldi
e contempla tempi molto molto lunghi.
Quando presentammo
il nostro occhiale di legno nel 2011
c'erano circa 3 produttori
di altri occhiali di legno.
Ad oggi ce ne sono circa dai 50 ai 60.
Ma quando loro presentarono
l’occhiale di legno,
noi presentammo l’occhiale
di legno colore con molta personalità.
Quando cercarono di copiarci
il design e il colore
presentammo l’occhiale di legno
vecchio di 48.000 anni.
Quando cercano di copiare
i materiali nobili
A quel punto noi avevamo già una catena
distributiva strutturata
e facendo leva sulla nostra manifattura
davamo un servizio di unicità
direttamente al nostro cliente.
Ad oggi abbiamo un piano di
sviluppo prodotti a 30 mesi
che risponde a furti di
proprietà intellettuale più o meno velata.
La terza condizione, dopo alta qualità
e velocità, è non avere il magazzino.
Il magazzino è uno spreco di risorse,
non averlo significa salvare l'ambiente.
La nostra coscienza ambientale è
il migliore consulente o professore
di economia del quale possiamo dotare
la nostra azienda.
Essere eco-friendly non significa
avere dei certificati sul proprio prodotto
o processo, ma significa
sviluppare una forma mentis
che tende ad eliminare il magazzino,
a ottimizzare la logistica.
E questo fa bene tanto all'ambiente
quanto più al budget consuntivo di spesa,
soprattutto in un paese come l'Italia,
dove la prima causa di fallimento
per piccole medie imprese è la mancanza
di liquidità nel breve termine.
Quindi avere magazzino, ovvero
denaro seduto in azienda inutilizzabile,
e' la peggiore minaccia
che possiamo portare in azienda.
Il quarto punto, dopo qualità, velocità
e zero magazzino
è avere il controllo e la consistenza
sui 4 elementi del piano marketing.
Il piano marketing sono quegli elementi
che utilizziamo per dialogare col mercato.
Sono il prodotto o servizio che
vendiamo, dove lo vendiamo,
a quanto lo vendiamo
e come lo raccontiamo.
Faber est suae quisque fortunae:
ciascuno è artefice della propria sorte.
Per essere artefice della propria sorte
quando si fa impresa bisogna avere
il controllo tanto a monte, sulla
ricerca e sviluppo, sulla manifattura,
sugli acquisti; quanto a valle, avere
la possibilità di avere
delle idee che dialoghino col mercato,
in termini di distribuzione
e in termini di comunicazione.
Da controllo a consistenza, in matematica
si dice che una teoria è consistente
quando è impossibile dimostrare
al suo interno una contraddizione.
Applicato a una piccola impresa questo
significa che un prodotto bello
deve essere venduto in un posto bello,
raccontato in un modo bello e presentato
al pubblico ad un prezzo che sia
coerentemente consistentemente bello alto.
l'essenziale è invisibile agli occhi,
diceva il piccolo principe:
un bel prodotto da solo non arriva
sul mercato senza l’aurea di magia
data dalla comunicazione
e dalla distribuzione.
Esistono 2 caratteristiche della qualità:
c'è la qualità e la qualità percepita.
Dei 4 elementi del piano marketing
solo uno porta qualità,
gli altri tre invece insistono
sulla qualità percepita,
ed e' quindi necessario
investire di conseguenza.
Il quinto e ultimo punto del paradigma
al quale aderimmo, dopo alta qualità,
velocità, zero magazzino e
controllo e consistenza
sugli elementi del piano marketing,
è avere esterni in azienda.
Ad oggi abbiamo formalizzato
un comitato nel quale siedono persone
che non ricoprono ruoli direttivi
in azienda, non sono immersi
nelle contingenze in azienda
e non sono del settore.
Grazie a questo comitato abbiamo avuto la
possibilità di avere sempre aria fresca.
Il comitato si esprime
insindacabilmente a maggioranza
e chi come me è inserito nella contingenza
dell'azienda è in minoranza.
Quindi questo ha permesso a chi come me
era inserito in azienda
e viveva di contingenza, di vedere
opportunità e minacce che non aveva visto.
Ed è parlando di prospettive diverse
che vorrei prenderne una qui ora con voi.
Vorrei fare un esercizio, vorrei provare
a testare il livello di consistenza
del sistema nel quale siamo inseriti,
nel sistema nel quale
un'impresa che innova è inserita.
Vorrei un po' utilizzare con voi
la mia azienda e il mio paradigma come
goniometro per misurare l'inclinazione a
recepire innovazione da parte del sistema.
Se noi facciamo questo esperimento
e questo esercizio scopriamo
che ci sono due grosse contraddizioni
nel sistema.
La prima: mio padre fonda una manifattura
circa 40 anni fa non aveva nulla
e quindi finanziò l'acquisto
dei macchinari con cambiali.
Noi nel 2014, con assunzioni
e fatturato in crescita,
abbiamo dovuto fare la stessa cosa.
Ed ecco quindi la prima contraddizione:
il sistema bancario deve sviluppare il
coraggio il desiderio e la professionalità
di riuscire intercettare
e supportare l'innovazione.
Strumenti come l'attribuzione del rating
basato sulla probabilità di fallimento
di un’impresa, non possono essere
gli unici strumenti per poter decidere
a chi o meno dare dei finanziamenti.
Il secondo elemento di contraddizione
che mina l'innovazione
è un velato fatalismo pessimistico
radicato,
è una sorta di freno a mano mezzo tirato,
una sorta di fiacchezza, frase non finita,
iper cautela nei confronti di chi innova,
ed è presente tanto nella classe
imprenditoriale quanto nel sistema
dove la classe imprenditoriale è inserita
e ora per forza contagiante
è presente anche sul mercato.
L'innovazione nasce dall’azione
contemporanea di due gruppi di persone.
Il primo sono le persone che desiderano
innovare, e quelle ci sono;
Il secondo sono le persone che decidono
di non ostacolare l'innovazione.
é solo grazie a questo secondo gruppo di
persone che visioni, innovazione, imprese,
paradigmi, nuove imprese anche qui,
sul nostro territorio,
potranno avere terreno fertile
e moltiplicarsi.
Quindi se abbiamo la possibilità
di influenzare il processo innovativo,
allora abbiamo anche l'obbligo di non
ostacolarlo quando lo vediamo arrivare.
Grazie
(Applausi)